there must be like propellant simulation
software because they can't surely can't
like
test this on actual physical
well back in the day they had to just
build it well you mean back back in the
day
walked up uphill in both ways it was
like I mean like any anything back in
the day before computers were you like
like
you just had to do it and like your
simulation or modeling was like a sheet
of paper where you're like calculating
stuff well but you can heat flux you
know like you can literally see how much
energy and how much heat is inside the
combustion chamber how much you know and
that is a measurable thing even without
a computer now I'm not near smart enough
to do any of this like I've never tried
measuring the heat flux of anything I
barely even know what that means I'm
just smart enough
but that is something that people would
calculate and they find out okay copper
you know does a better job of
transferring the heat between the walls
of it and into the propellant blah blah
blah compared to XYZ
um so yeah you know materials people I
like I've met just in all walks of life
especially just through MIT through
everywhere where there's some people
are just like a hundred X smarter than
anyone you've ever met at a particular
thing like you mentioned copper they'll
know the heat dissipation through
different materials they'll understand
that like more than it's like holy
it's possible for human beings to deeply
understand a thing dude Aerospace is
full of that you'll have people that are
so niche in some thing that no one the
average person has never even remotely
thought of yet this person has done it
40 000 different ways in a you know in a
an environment being like well we found
out that if we turn it four degrees that
way and add four percent niobium you
know like just things you're like
what is your life and how do you know
this and the funny thing about them they
usually don't think it's a big deal
yeah they're usually like they're
they're so nonchalant about it that if
you don't actually you have to know
enough you actually have to know quite a
lot to appreciate
how much more they know yeah because
otherwise you won't even notice it
because there are popular culture
doesn't celebrate the intricacies of uh
scientific or engineering Mastery which
is interesting there's all these people
that lurk in the shadows they're just
Geniuses yes like you see you'll have
like the LeBrons who are like good at
basketball so we understand that they're
good at basketball they do this thing
with the ball and the hoop and they do
like it really well better than a lot of
other people under pressure like we
celebrated big public spectacles yeah
look how great they are yeah but like
the people like yeah as at these
aerospace companies in NASA SpaceX
the kind of stuff they're doing just I
mean there's Geniuses there and it's
actually really inspiring I mean I've
um I've interacted with a lot of
brilliant people in the software world
and maybe because I don't deeply
understand a lot of Hardware stuff
materials engineering mechanical
engineering those people seem like so
much smarter I mean it's always like the
grass is green or whatever the
expression is but there's a depth of
understanding that Engineers have that
do like mechanical engineering that's
just awe-inspiring uh to me well not to
get too like uh X well I don't know what
the word would be introverted or
something or whatever but that's
actually kind of the whole point of
everyday astronaut like that's almost
the whole point of what I do each year
from the beginning I did a thing called
the Astro Awards trying to be like an
award show hoping to you know lift up
and celebrate and and China Spotlight on
the people that are actually doing the
hard work and try to treat them like the
the rock stars that they are that we
don't know about and I think that's one
of the things that for sure I think you
know I think Elon definitely helped make
space flight cool helped make that like
a celebration thing where people are
physically out cheering for rockets and
Science and Space exploration but I
think that's just the beginning you know
I think like this should be a thing
where the general public uh looks to
these people as as the coolest ones as
the the coolest places to work as the
most important things you know sports
are great and everything I'm a big
formula one fan and things like that but
you know at the same time like if we
should be celebrating the people doing
this crazy work you know clocking in
countless hours just trying to figure
out this one little thing that's going
to help us further our understanding I
mean what's cooler than a giant thing
with a really hot fire that goes boom
and goes up into the air I mean like
there's no it's it's like to me like
bridges are inspiring it's like uh
incredible architecture design and like
the humans are able to uh work against
nature build these gigantic metal things
but like rockets yeah with like a tiny
little humans on top of them yeah flying
out into space it's like it's the
coolest possible thing everything comes
together all the different disciplines
coming together for the high stakes
drama of
you know riding that super powerful
thing up away from the thing we call
home Earth it's like it's so amazing
exactly so freaking amazing well I think
that's kind of part of my like story arc
is I I just used to be a huge car and
motorcycle guy like I just loved you
know things that go fast and you know
are loud and go fast and make lots of
power and at the end of the day like at
some point you realize nothing goes
faster and it's louder and makes more
power or the rocket you know I think
that's I think that's kind of where
where I eventually just ended up you
know wound up there just because there
is nothing cooler than that yeah that's
the ultimate level it reaches the car
guy is to become a rock guy yeah 100 and
at some point some Car Guys literally
become rocket guys and strap Rockets to
cars and try and break land speed
records you know like it's it's the same
universe here